you
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
you
you
you
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
you
you
you
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to GameSpot and
it's cam and save here we are gonna play
fallout 76 brought you by Bethesda said
we're we're back on gamespot Street in
this warm and cozy really really does
feel good to be back but yeah we're
playing fallout 76 as camps here brought
to you by Bethesda cam full disclosure
this is my first time leaving the ball
today
oh really yeah oh really well you you
have ventured a little but I have kept
this super fresh well that's good that's
good I mean I can be I could be your
guide to the very beginning of the game
who's this
messed up messed up guy behind all my
work I believe that is you it is my
character let's have a closer look at
him right so come on get in there buddy
absolutely appalling look at that smiley
was actually surprised I've said him to
surprise your surprised face and your
horror face are very similar
IRL yeah that's true it's true and would
you like to take a look at me yes yes
let's have a look at your character sir
I mean my guy is I basically put all the
damage on and here you are there he is
yeah yeah I like here you've gone for
the blonde kind of mustache you know I
was thinking here I was just sort of
feeling like the styles but I've never
been brave enough to try myself okay I
did later realize that he reminds me of
a character from an anime watch all
right okay yeah I won't go into but if
anyone in the comments has any idea who
I'm talking about feel free to let me
know speaking of comments Oh cam and I
are gonna be in the YouTube chat we are
literally looking at right now
apparently the audio volume is quite low
oh no apparently some people saying it's
fine we have we have sleepy Gary he was
doing our whole whole stream so Gary I'm
sure he's on the audio if anyone needs
to speak directly to say hey sleepy Gary
do this please sleepy Gary please shall
we head out into the vault please may we
may we
go right adventure begins man it's
bright oh boy it's bright
well my giant face for the Learning
stream that's the surprise of the
Apocalypse
so tell you bit about the backstory mark
my character said I figured that
although we've been safe inside the
vault I put all the damage on my guy's
face that's possible because I figured
that he's the club I'm pretty clumsy in
real life and I think my character yeah
and has just been like constantly
walking in the doors and just yeah he's
my sister this is the trouble he finds a
safe environment oh is this you know
because I suppose everyone has to leave
on reclamation day which it is by the
way yes everyone is supposed to be
leaving with with full you know full joy
and comfort and everything like we've
not roughed it at all except that were
you were you a brawler like no like you
know no just clumsy just I just fell
over a lot I've gone for full face muck
on mine oh yeah yeah I just didn't wash
that's my backstory here we are it's
details here yeah just for good work out
the shower inside the vault saves
character didn't wash your hair that's
how you've got such the fix of the hair
isn't it it's all just like you make
your own make your own style your
profile look is terrifying just looking
at me like I think I'm just gonna keep
this I just I set this expression if you
if you're wondering how you do this you
basically in photo mode so if you hit
start you can go into photo mode where
was it here we go and then you can hit Y
and you can literally choose your
expression over here so actually
currently my expressions on none but
what I had before was G that's wave
that's far too boring let's let's get my
surprised I like that okay so I should
be surprised there we go that's better
that's better just just gentle amusement
yeah you look yeah you look amused let's
say that all right shall we shall we
venture into the world
first of all can we just breathe it in
breathe it in
this is like the Bethesda thing the
first view that's true wow this is the
first time in a Fallout game as well
where you look out and you don't see a
very desolate bleak well this is
actually kind of lush yeah well I mean
if that's it's true to the narrative
right because yes this part wasn't
directly bombed wonderful news and
there's a lot of robots here though we
have Pennington now a lot of these guys
are gonna are gonna give us story bits
and bobs but we're just gonna we're just
gonna move on and just venture I kind of
ignore this story to begin with I think
he's just venture off and see how far we
can get and I think I think we should
just pick a direction and just go you
had a direction in mind didn't you um
potentially oh I found a note I need you
to make the monthly scouting around
vault 76 these doors have got to open
sometimes I sure do oh well this guy was
meant to observe and he his observations
either going really really well really
badly well have you have you robbed him
I mean yeah I'm trying I'm currently
doing this all right taking all of the
things there we go he didn't have much
let's see what did he have I've done a
bit of a take all nice all right
let's sell this which way should we go I
think we should go well we have a look
at them again first of all ok look on
your screen then soon so we are right on
the map edge well more or less yeah we
can't go back a little way so I have a I
have a photo here yeah potentially this
was the location oh really
we could try okay all right that's more
to the right I believe so
what's happening I'm being attacked I
was a little tiny bugs helping how dare
you punch it punch the tiny to keep
robot yes am I still surprised
look at me you have to look at me okay
hold still
yes still surprised that's the OL
cross-eyed can I'm good I'm pleased
there's more little angry robots
liberators yes I remember these from
when I played the beta a good punching
will soar them out
now because of the because of the way it
works we aren't going to end up in in an
actual fight are we no no we can do but
I think we should first just get to
grips get to grips with the wilderness
yeah
and it looks like you and I both get an
opportunity to loot as well yeah where I
have been
oh I've been I've been leading all
triggering ah no that reichstag rag stag
doe can't speak to them but they are
here running away gentle well this one's
slightly floaty but let's go over up we
go
I know no I've noticed this in the beta
there's actually musical instruments oh
I found some simple hidden around so why
don't you why don't you raid the medical
box there while I just share an age of
the banjo this is just like the work was
today in the office serve me sitting
around on a banjo every day you taking
taking medical supplies it's perfect
okay that's enough of that my banjo
skills are already excellent mmm we need
to pick a direction we haven't picked we
haven't really picked a direction but
just just casual oh you're finding stuff
yeah I missed this
there was an under the stairs yeah
there's always telling me all right I'm
gonna you that kind of loser are you
like kind of like I'm not doing anything
movers away this is mine
well I just took the metal bucket I
don't think you can take one of those
two okay I'm gonna take a quick look at
my pip-boy and see what kind of stuff
I've got as well okay good plan meet me
to meet you
actually no no I'm not gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna have a look at the machete oh
that's actually that's actually useful
yep uh-oh do you want to go to the
Mothman museum I mean obviously yeah
shall we do that it's not far
it's not far and there's a pig nearby
apparently and that sounds like a
wonderful day what I think I picked up
and so what am I wearing oh oh you're
wearing a nice hat by the way are you
not wearing as it is reclamation day yes
a good point all right all right let me
uh
see what I got a right bumpy away over a
right trigger here we go machete yeah
yes yeah I'm gonna put my glasses on oh
all I did was pick up another jump seat
let's go some Manny's ready to face the
waste Hill until I find new clothes okay
I refuse to be constrained by the blue
jumpsuit Sam I've worn that for many
years inside the vault it's time for
something different so follow me I've
kind of laid a rough Waypoint right so I
know where we're going in theory now I
keep your eyes peeled for robots because
there are many angry robots in West
Virginia I don't think I've never been
to West Virginia but I'm assuming that's
not the case a customs when you arrive
yeah beware the road West Virginia
beware the robots which are see by the
way on the chat says welcome back I'm
glad to see you again in GameSpot thank
you it is good to be here is talking
just to me but thank ya though this is
part three of three things that we have
done in conjunction with fallout that's
tricks that's true so you have also been
producing two other videos how many yeah
yeah if you're interested to know that
about the science of survival post
apocalypse and then those tips was a
reality check featuring our good friend
professor so you know he's smart faster
Luis Darnell I'm talking all about how
one would go about surviving in a real
post-apocalyptic wasteland yeah like
this so you know not one where
everything is radiated but where the
kind of vestiges of society are still
lingering and how you can put these
things to good use yeah little things I
learned such as one of the things you
the first place is you want to go if
there's an apocalypse yeah it's the golf
course because you can pick up a golf
buggy and inside the golf buggy I mean
obviously it's fun to resurrect you can
take care of very particular type of
deep-cycle battery yes which is
incredibly useful to parrot for powering
your post-apocalyptic civilization there
you go find out more about watching a
reality check in the meantime he's uh
he's actually done a really interesting
TED talk about how to survive yeah not
me yeah this is Luis Daniel
so I found a workbench nice I found a
wall fan I'm sure
who's gonna be a little too early for me
to craft anything yeah it is oh thanks
friend
very very much I'm just checking to
early just checking
gonna have to do a little bit more
leting before I can just some dirty
water over here in the wall I know how
much you like dirty water serve it's a
pain great yeah it is just here oops
thank you I've got boiled water Oh what
what I got dirty war what is this I'm
sorry for at least we can see there's
some sort of randomization or some sort
of discrepancy in the items that you
loot oh man I could go mad on the loot
in here I need to slow it down tab check
out this lumberyard this is this is
creepy if I was a ghoul I would hide in
here
oh my game a look my cat may look a bit
like a ghoul but this is a perfect
Google hiding spot right I'm coming off
to you although I don't see any girls
so yeah that's you know you don't want
to jump into ghoul territory is super
early don't you so I'm well aware we
don't have any guns yet no I think we're
gonna have to adventure further to find
that I got a shot glass though so should
we do well we're ready to celebrate and
a power really coil there is a lot
because obviously one of the biggest
things about fall at 76 yeah
that's new is there is the crafting
system which we will explore at some
point using our camp we forgot to pick
up our camp unit we can get ready yes
we'll go back to the vault later that's
literally cuz we were like oh let's get
to the entrance for the start of the
stream we didn't pick up for our camp
unit oh my goodness
like like find you oh but we sorry we
can I think we can probably just find
the overseers and use that when it's
dead we're already doing really well
Oh sad are you with me because I spotted
some hostiles why actually I'm not sure
they respond or protect my way are you
why are you behind the thing I'm trying
to find a way through the fence oh yeah
see I knew you'd be like this playing a
game with you he's wandering off come on
said you you're like the MPS do you like
the AI NPC getting stuck on things to
catch up I'm here
I'm here there you go you sworn to carry
my burdens sure I'm alright I like the
way these two are walking in perfect
synchronicity look at that that's okay
well if you put it like that they're
level five sab I think they're gonna be
tough yeah let's see if they are they
friendly I think they're friendly yeah
these are friendly protectron I guess
yeah let's leave em alone
they seem like good guys I'm really glad
they're friendly because yeah yeah
because leaves that fight super they
would mess us up oh no I think where are
we on the map exactly okay yeah we're
going in the right way oh yeah it's
almost like we meant to do that
I'm digging these looks cam I'm digging
oh nice god rays yeah very nice God
raised them right I'm gonna chase after
you follow me
uh-huh no what have we here on it's
nothing exciting I thought that was like
a crate with something in it but Oh duct
tape very useful yeah I feel like that's
what I've got the most off so far duct
tape yeah you can take the video
producer out of the know the real world
well that's that is the phrase of the
video producer or I suppose any
technician which is if it moves and it
shouldn't dr. duct tape and if it should
and it doesn't wd-40 as well they say
there are other lubricant brands
available I imagine right I'm not
finding any weapons oh hello wait a
minute
alpine river cabin look at this nice
nice
we set a waypoint that we want to go to
yes I already have oh you have all right
it's the waypoint on my compass I am
your Waypoint yeah we also need to find
me so I think you actually like brought
the waypoint in onto my compass as well
yeah she lets not sprint Lewis Seaver
stamina and just to enjoy the views
it is a top the industry I really really
know essentially the the world feels
really really nice to walk around in
yeah it feels for minutes I'm like am i
playing scary
yeah because everything's this living
living things on the road or tunnel kind
of look to it but yeah you can I mean
there's loads of stuff in here that will
remind you of other Bethesda games such
as Skyrim exactly where we are still
going let's just check our progress
yep making good progress towards the
whoops towards the the Mothman museum I
know it's gonna slightly abandon you
camera I know it's it's classic cam we
can go anywhere let's go to the museum
I'm here to have engaged myself in some
kind of class except I see him I'm
getting him I don't see him he's all
there he's the thing I'm hitting with my
ah oh God he's quite tough
you got one down already yeah yes I got
his meat that's what I did delicious
good job delicious oh and I found a
duffel bag full of pre-war money it's
mine you can't have it okay oh boy up in
the trees oh yeah what did you find the
trees you know the trees can see all
right is there anything anything good
there is one skeleton exactly one that's
not we can't share it okay fine you
haven't I shall continue onwards along
the path now when I played the beta I
was very quickly attacked and killed by
protect Ron's yes I don't know if I was
just unlucky and we've got lucky this
time but yeah and we haven't actually
met any other human beings no yes I
wonder it if how we will know if there's
any others in our world uh I think there
are lick lick we have Jake and Eddie two
four six eight over there yeah and we
have got some new new oh yeah we got a
few people on yeah yeah yeah we caught
mr. vault seventies I suppose
yeah William oh wait someone's beat us
to Mothman museum oh let's go join them
yeah hundred percent as we go the wrong
way this way following you I mean we
could go by the road that roads are
boring let's go this way
[Music]
now what's the what's the what's the
chat seeing how people are making fun of
my pronunciation of beta look let's just
remember what the language is called
yeah what's the English like just
kidding yeah it's been so long since we
did mods haven't seen these two in time
yes yeah well we still do been a modding
again we did we did disappear off the
scene for about a year but yeah we're
around yep we are known fans of
Bethesda's games no wait there's
something up ahead it doesn't look like
a museum I've been in museums and this
looks like big pile of rocks come on oh
what's that oh I'm hearing it as well
that was a gun yeah it is that mean is
that being shot at us Marek marigold
Pavillion I'm not getting hurt so I
think if it's a PvP that we have not
engaged something going on in there Oh
what did you find
oh it's it's ghouls
it's ghouls yes help leave some for me
I'm stuck in a rock oh no come on I must
fight oh my word I'm doing terribly I'm
stuck his service is scorched sorry to
be specific gorge yeah take all right
I'm gonna change up my weapons how did
you weapons what did you find I believe
I found a it was a pipe bolt-action
pistol nice there we go and a Molotov
where did you find it off the young man
that I took the life ok that's very kind
of you
this feral girl has nothing oh no I
don't think I can leave if you've
already lit seeds don't worry
I found a wood left leg it was this
person here if you want to check which
one just here under where I am where are
you come to me anyway let's say oh there
you are oh yes now I can wonderful good
thoughts say alright let's let's let's
have a look at our gear I think I might
actually have fun have some clothes I
can wear let's find out
no I have a wooden left leg which I will
wear okay slowly you just just wrote a
few planks of wood to your study just
it's wonderful Armour you just jealous
of my leg armor look at that I'm just
gonna find some wood and in case my
entire body and would threaten stream
well I'm a crotch height that's good for
you okay
let's run this way yeah I've got em nine
bullets no I'm gonna six and I killed
him oh I find six more this is going
very well is there anything else I can
strap to my forty there's lots of scrap
wood surely I can just append this well
just an entire suit of armor made of
wood really yeah it's like the episode
of Futurama wooden bender I want to be
wooden bender now again I'm sure that I
don't have enough stuff I can make some
throwing knives at this point for the
bench okay yeah but you do that and I'm
gonna frost live inside this dumpster no
at this point to make new weapons we
would still require a few more items of
loops that's fine yes we're not far from
the mod oh I can see the Mothman museum
all right come on goodies that's it down
there anyway down there you say on your
way take really okay you're just
stealing your being busy I'm glad that
you thing seeing how this is this is
working alright
down we go mmm
people commenting on your wonderful
armor cam good oh wait I see you ghoul
did I get it
you did it oh wow I think it might have
already been dead and it's now turned
into oh it's radioactive
oh great back it up well that went very
well now I wonder if the Mothman museum
is gonna be full of Mothman because of
course the the famous creatures from
West Virginia's kind of how'd you
describe it Lori that Laurie yeah
they're populate this game and I do know
that Mothman are one of them so where I
am off man
I would certainly check it the Mothman
museum I mean I'd be there hunting
Mothman I didn't know anyone was gonna
find me here at the and I was passing
through yeah what a coincidence
passing through the Mothman museum oh
look I find our first our first human
being oh oh my word
their armor is way better than my like
Oh a whole bunch nice armor do you have
any wooden leg armor for my other leg
greetings friends greetings invite pitch
trade eye candy my first up all right
I'm gonna give him a Blood Pact do you
want a mouse so I was so busy selecting
my hello
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh he's got a sniper rifle and it's not
afraid to show it
oh there is a there's more weaponry up
here oh really yeah Oh jump Marlow that
was good jump good jump save solid jump
what I made it oh no I didn't I did the
other thing and there's yet another
weapon up here do you want to take this
just make sure that it's yeah so then
it's gone it's gone forever yeah we can
boss man
under did you get it now I got I've got
something else Oh what did you get let
me check also I need to do some em some
favoriting of my my weapons I think so
oh it's level 5 so I can't use this yet
but it's a recoil compensated
bolt-action pipe bolt-action rifle nice
as soon as I can get that working I'm
gonna be all over it
nice Oh what have I done oh I'm in the
same I don't have enough levels for that
either
yeah so I can't level up have you
leveled up yet
oh yeah cuz again cuz we rushed out of
the vault at home we didn't really level
up I gotta level up my charisma cuz my
face is just already pretty charismatic
so let's do that I'm going to go agility
to start with okay cool alright let's
continue into the Mothman museum and one
of the biggest things I differences I
noticed when playing Mbita
or the beta few Americans watching ya is
that there's a day/night cycle obviously
and I know that's been the case in many
Fallout games the photo Bethesda games
for a long time you've always got a
dynamic cycle but you can't force it you
know it's set so if you want to be like
yeah it's dark I want to see this place
in the light time you literally have to
wait yep you you can rest but it you
know you rest in real time so or in the
like timeline that functions is in this
game so you really do have to deal with
the dark hours yeah it's it changes it
quite a lot that's part of the shared
world experience well exactly yeah can I
jump across to here I can I'm on the
roof
oh I found some new clothes about I know
I haven't well let me take that chance
gonna be a bit disappointed in their ice
alright chat don't worry won't let me
take his clothes where tinkers workbench
let's see what we can do I think this
guy is he's really keen to be part of
our team and frankly who could blame him
yeah I mean we've got the licks and the
style I've got not the ability to make
much so that's fine with let's not
bother with this right now there's a
couple of guys here to loot by the way
oh yeah just yeah your man there yeah I
got on the side he was one I thought I
could get some clothes off but I wasn't
able to you Oh with this guy this guy Oh
ten millimeter pistol which I'm not high
enough level to use yet and I'm minding
its alright well that's what we've got
to go and kill some things to get that
level level up sweet sweet to level up
exactly alright let's move further into
the museum yeah I think our friend is
causing some trouble 100% sure respect
so are we gonna go into the church or we
gonna go in this way it's going to
church okay
good plan oh I like slightly a petrified
corpses oh yeah oh if you search them
they turn in crumble - oh there's
another guy in here horrible stuff oh
yeah so there is dark oh there's a lot
of them a lot of supplies in here a
dishrag for example you can call
therefore I should probably be a little
bit more efficient with my Hey oh I was
gonna say who's hitting me it's smooshed
alright even noise have you got him yeah
I mean somebody did let's it might have
been me it wasn't me but him my bin oh
here's another - busy - busy looting
okay so we've got a lot of these little
bolt-action rifles so I think we could
probably just mantle one or two of these
get some more bits get some parts yes
think exactly I don't know where the
wrench is I see a girl of sorts scorched
even Oh
this court oh sorry terrible job of
shooting at it in your hands
no maybe I hit it oh they they have they
have like weapons yeah oh you everything
good job here whoa Oh there's quite a
few them well I think I've got a grenade
actually let me uh of course you can't
just pause it you have to go in hi yeah
go I definitely picked up a
fragmentation grenade but apparently I
didn't oh well
Oh Piper Evolver hello yes Oh ones
behind us oh you know anymore headshot
nice headshot a fine hit oh thank you
I'm still good Oh yep Pip Boy light
thank you very much game well--that's
remind you to go thank you
Oh who's that so much trying to do the
looting as quickly as I can to take up
too much oh this is this is a really
lucrative way of doing it though killing
these scores people yeah I mean they're
already scorched how good can their life
be exactly really we're doing them a
favor ultimately it's your welcome kind
of situation and let's have a look I'm
just gonna quickly jump back in here and
see if there's any way that I can
dismantle some of the pieces also I
should probably give myself just a
little bit of Health oh yeah how is your
health - I know we're about the same
yeah we're doing all right
oh I can see I'm looking your screen
it'll literally shows you your health on
my screen because we're in a team yep
wonderful there's some scissors I
actually think I remember them saying
sorry I was looking at some things that
we need to build and it definitely said
you need scissors so I've got that now
nice so while you're doing all that
looting yeah I reckon I'm gonna go to
the chat open my map
okay chat here's the map where shall we
go next we're mean we're gonna finish
exploring the Mothman museum of course
but once we've done that where would you
like to go
there is a whole load oh my goodness
it's like an is this like a mini-golf
thing I don't know like a waterpark said
there's a waterpark up here
what else a giant butterfly and I assume
that's man-eating some sort of turtle
what are people thinking what have we
got okay
there we go nice do these guys read the
chat well and reading that I think you
have your answer sir or madam anyone go
get your camp is everything fine well go
and do that so we'll go back to vol 76
we can think we can fast travel there it
has already been there Lake area go for
crocodile says crime okay the lake area
these little bits big croc all right so
here's the plan Seb we're gonna go back
to vault 76 and get the thing we forgot
okay then we're gonna go with visit the
crocodile okay sounds like a wonderful
wonderful day okay
oh nice glasses friend oh oh wait you
just took all your clothes off
oh well I fast traveled back to about 76
is that what happens my clothes Javel my
clothes have to get there safely and
then I travel on after all right well
how weird okay first I have successfully
arrived but how did you first travel
there's too many people
Oh easy enough all right in the meantime
I'm going to head back inside can I head
back inside can you head back inside can
you know I head back inside maybe we did
we did I miss the one opportunity to do
that it's all right it says track we can
find the overseers camp we maybe we can
pick one up there okay that's hilarious
oh you've arrived well with them with my
wooden leg yeah so I guess it's not
possible to get back inside once you're
out well look we're making these
mistakes so you guys don't have to yeah
you're welcome yeah we definitely can't
get back inside there
all right let's um
do do we want to go and get the the camp
from where the I know where that is okay
yeah let's go exactly okay okay so
follow me follow me this is the way
you're kind of meant to go the way the
game points you at the beginning but
yeah you choose here we go let's go and
say hello huh level two down here
let's get we're not alone continue this
way oh you have yeah you're getting your
receives log well done good job oh yeah
we're meant to turn that off that's
probably a good idea how do we turn off
the in-game chat mm-hmm let's figure
that one out
well you figure that out I'm gonna go on
an adventure
mmm I imagine it's in settings audio
voice chat mode that's where you want to
turn to you're saying team Tungus or
none this chunga this so you have to
turn voice Chapman so what go into
setting set and change a voice chat mode
to none okay that's what you do all
right cool I missed a flower back it up
okay I got it
pretty sure this is the way I went last
time
so agency um people in the chat who
played the beta or beta depending on how
you like to say it who played it I'm
interested to know if you find any cool
places that we should go with it with or
without our camp and no no in the
settings of the game seven so go to the
map there you go and now hit you can you
go you got it yeah here what is going on
down here
Oh protect your on I'm on my way where I
might be friendly I mean it's got a
giant circular saw in the front which is
probably friendly where have you gone
I'm down the hill should probably take a
stim pack as well as you know see I've
already taken a few stimpaks already
after our first they seem friendly okay
no no worries right so hey you are yes I
believe we are going in the correct
direction yep
find you overseers camp we just
basically follow this road what have you
found
indeed frog kill it
could be dangerous she's probably Blood
Pack and frog egg that's that sounds
like a good combination percent I'm
taking both of those let's protect a
truck is that the same one that you saw
over there I think so yeah yeah I'm just
waiting for you by this by this lake
yeah I'm on my way
now you can collect water which because
which is very advisable do because you
will you will get thirsty and if you're
not quench your thirst when you play
this game ah what is this
it's dead is what it is okay that's
right you better run dear I'm a hunter
okay
very mildly irradiated yeah I got my
first caps oh sweet nice okay shall we
go onwards yeah Oh a leather chess piece
uh-huh survivor
amazing where was that I imagine I can
do the same it was inside there wait
wait look at me look at me I'm slowly
piecing together some semblance of
clothing yes very very - emblems I
wouldn't call that clothing that's not
quite but we're getting there I'm just
saying that if you turned up to work
wearing just that I wouldn't say nice
clothing can what if I lead really sad
wouldn't you oh let's check out this
let's check out this Shack over here I
bet there might be some more clothing
for me oh wait what a scorch this yummy
Oh yep
don't get it someone did oh where is it
gone
where's it go it's dead no no there's
one other way okay it's another one
got it yeah lots of stuff on this oh my
god really what is going on I'm not even
seeing that oh wow this guy had
everything he's got everything what's
going on uh I'm now over encumbered Oh
am i I think that not meant to be this
way maybe it is well I'm going to dress
myself and drop quite a lot of things me
too
oh my word which oh yeah I mean I have
identical leather chair species which
one's the nicest right arm this one how
you how'd you know oh the condition yeah
exactly
smart smart interesting oh no I dropped
a rhyme that's pretty fine someone's
running around around us I don't know if
it's a friend so that's good okay I
might have been overly greedy here it's
possible
in fact I've definitely been overly
greedy I'm just dropping anything I'm
not wearing it's getting dropped oh no
my Whidden wait wait hey my wooden left
leg is not going anywhere all right
observe me actually I can do this myself
I don't need you busy
there we go lights on please oh come on
don't worry people hit by light was on
there we go I think I finally finally
got to the end of that so ever look well
you haven't worn anything
you still look exactly the same really
where is Mike you look ridiculous it's
true according to this I am wearing
everything so oh it must just be under
your your suit
wait who is this oh it's that guy
I gotta be mad earlier right we need to
finish movie as well what about now what
about now look at me now yeah that's
better yeah okay get good good good well
done you know put things on thank you
there's more up here let's assume that
this this person wasn't meant to have
this much stuff
when a notes message to Sammy I'm gonna
read this responders every night there's
more of them in Skype okay this sounds
like a pre-apocalypse note but we've had
our map updated for Abbey's bunker
perfect know that well you know what
let's let's one thing at a time
yes go get our camp come on oh that's
not you that's some other guy right this
way I am following you
surely how can you mistake anyone else
for me I've got a uniquely style sense
also I think I'm over encumbered which
is why I can't sprint so let me drop a
whole bunch of stuff before we proceed I
have so many things here I think it was
all the weapons I picked up as well
wasn't it yeah I picked up a lot of
weapons I had to drop a few oh yeah and
I'm not sure we were meant to have quite
so many bits and pieces there but hey
what are you gonna do I'm not gonna
complain so I can that the less good
things I'm actually scrapping some of my
less good things here oh that's smart
at the at the scrap point yeah why am I
still over encumbered no I'm not
where's my what's my carry weights oh
yeah up did it perfectly amazing
okay very nothing okay okay I will also
I'm gonna do some modification and
repairs then if you did some scrapping
allow me to see if I'm good at modding
right so what are we on a mod chess
piece Oh old leather it's all going off
is it someone I'm busy making some oK
you've got it I believe in you I'm gonna
win this fight I believe in you
oh I can modify my wouldn't my wood left
leg perfect oh no I can't I know I can't
there we go oh sorry I won the fight I
want to fight
all right weapons as always do and if
you're a fan of looting this game is
going to there is quite a lot of looting
favorite that one that one that one that
one that one great alright how's your
how's your modding going um well I
boiled the leather on my leather chest
piece that felt pretty good
I actually didn't do any any escape
listen repairs let's go get our camp no
okay okay very very quickly very very
quick okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna just soldier on into
the night oh I see frogs I'm gonna hunt
frogs slowly frog lead the frog I get
him nope I did not I'm gonna leave this
let's go oh I'm terrible with this rifle
hey there we go
actually you get some xp for seeing
frogs a victimless crime excess it's
gonna be cam in the future for in
reality just wasting ammunition on
shooting frogs sick all I'm telling you
that frog had some uranium ore and now
it's mine
alright onwards oh hello hello toolbox
rock paper scissors oh I'm over
encumbered again that was some really
heavy scissors yeah let me just Chuck's
I do you like how we get different
things in here there's no guarantee that
we're gonna find the same thing Knight
has very much fallen so yeah we're gonna
have to start working away through this
well we're all we're almost our
destination I really need to find some
more clothes I'm just watching me on
your screen yep I really do right a bit
serious it is it's so different being
locked into nighttime oh what's this
find some stock yeah nice there are so
many items in this game I know a lot of
it is just so you can put it into the
kind of crafting like yes
but it's pretty cool all right we have
found the overseers camp perfect and
there's a camp here that we can can we
have can I have you
we're going to come over here oversee
his log camp there we go
build a replica or relocate your account
by opening a bit boy impressing lb we
can just relocate our camp okay what's
perfect move camp yes I've got my camp
uh-huh
we didn't break it what do you do
nothing see you giggling over there
nothing worries me said apparel let's
let's take a look at each other all
right I'm just getting some wood scraps
here you better not have a wooden left
leg I'll be oh my god how did you make
that this is mine that's amazing kick
your surprised face surprised how did
you where did you make that just over
here where this guy is your good friend
is modify I can't use it because he's
using it and it's gonna jump I'm getting
it's gonna annoy him into the one fight
seems that we need to get more of is uh
screws in order to build many of these
interesting I can build a combat knife
and I don't have the pieces required to
build a board Oh No well you fish stuff
you need the board yeah that's true
all right boxing's Oh some screws here
we go oh there's largest thing haha lots
of lots and lots and lots of stuff here
great okay just grabbing everything that
I don't think I'll need so I think I'd
be able to build some stuff so is this
um so tell me about the camp system the
cam so um well we can you know I would
fall out for you could go to particular
locations and you could basically set up
a camp and then
build various structures yeah no oh yeah
I was gonna use that you distracted me
sorry friend that's all right where's
this is the one I want I can build the
syringe er so I'm thinking is exactly
what I'm gonna do
fires blanks syringes but yes what I was
going to say was that you can um I'm
gonna get him warned American patriot
suit there you go but yeah so the camp
think this means you can kind of do you
can create stuff anywhere you like
mm-hmm which is fantastic so we can go
we can find a great spot in the
wilderness and set up our own home
well let's do exactly that okay well
first Oh first I need to wear my what
I've just made offer a kind thumbs up
for that as well thank you
am I looking at all right we're all
looking extremely patriotic very much
into oh you can't see my wooden my
wooden leg can you no it's okay no no no
it's there no it's not happening
taking a huff then I think my outfit is
complete okay so we've got our camp
we're doing well I mean we promised the
next thing we would do is go investigate
the alligator that's always said so okay
that is all the way up here long journey
realize I do have a small quest there to
construct a weapon so I'm going to quit
okay what am i okay I'm gonna make the
syringe you're gonna make the syringe
okay I may modify some items
I'm a repair some items to let me see
what can I do can i repair my wooden
left leg I can with some wood some with
adhesive Oh pip-boy mm eh
yeah that's what I've got yeah then the
boiled leather okay okay I've also just
leveled up oh you can repair it you can
repair all your all your items to full
condition that's great yeah right now
we're talking
all right you leveled up I'm gonna uh
I'm just gonna create a weapon as well
so I can try and level up a little bit
is this one here yet the weapons
workbench see what I [ __ ] modify some
guns actually I've got quite a few so
I've got this I've got this short
hunting rifle
like what if I repair that okay and then
if I want to modify it
Macon's I don't have any of the bits oh
no I can no I've already got that
what do I need for the quite a few bits
uses further the reflex sight there yeah
it's not gonna happen is it
I don't have any of the bits I need ok
well let's let's adventure and go and
find the bits we need all right fair
enough
what about pipe revolver well I can
change the barrel I can put a longer
barrel on my paper over it done all
right
LD hey up ya there how can you level up
so much I'm very good shot I think that
might be it okay that's fine I'm ready
I'm done let's go alright I'm following
you we are going to it still says we
haven't done something here I'll craft a
weapon I still need different I just you
know what so to get to craft the weapon
that take all the items to the left in
that orange container oh you've already
have yeah yeah just quickly make
something make anything like ever you
like oh yeah I was just trying to modify
it yeah you're right I should craft
something okay okay and you made the
syringe oh did you I did make this
syringe er I'm gonna take a quick look
at that I'm gonna make some throwing
knives yeah I crafted a weapon I've
already got some pipe guns a couple of
empty syringes even better oh yeah
hatchet cool I think I also level up not
sure what did you make the syringe er um
I used all my adhesive nevermind that's
okay that's okay I'll just have to live
with it right onwards to the alligator
yes which is where is that again
the one thing I've learned is find the
overseer in the in the flatwoods know
well that's that's the next the next bit
is best the next part of the mission
gets to find the overseer which we are
not going to do we're gonna ignore that
and we're gonna head in the complete
opposite direction
I've heard that syringes are quite
effective against alligators good
well then we should be just fine then I
know make sure you collect some water or
drink some water
how is my general thirst and hunger
doing alright thirst is good yeah my
thirst is not great I'm drinking some
more there you go might have a little
bit of radaway or similar yeah I'm
definitely routing myself up right now
yeah 15 rads with every drink mmm okay
but let's cross this cross this river
okay we've got a bit of a walk ahead of
us okay we can eat up our Sprint's for
this Oh am i over encumbered again have
a look I am over encumbered again so
waking up to mouldings oh that is a hell
of a walk that is a mighty wait the chat
demands and the chat gets yes I have
literally won one gram or one not sure
what that is a kilo whatever it is I'm
one and one thing over so I'm gonna get
rid of I'm gonna have some dirty water
and some cotton candy bytes perfect am i
there yet not quite let's have some
potato crisps oh god I just took some
psycho accidentally I'm just now eating
things in my inventory - there we go I'm
now light enough to sprint let's go
no none of us have tried their new VAT
system yet I've noticed in combat
mmm-hmm so we'll have to try that this
time next time we get to find ourselves
in a fight we're gonna on our way to the
alligator sale we are gonna encounter
lots of exciting well I mean we're
walking over a decent part of the map to
get over to the Allegan exactly but I
think you know well the whole point of
this is that we can adventure literally
anywhere yeah so why not
the best I didn't want us to go straight
for the alligator then they shouldn't
have put a big alligator on the map I
know inviting me what is this fire can
mushroom all right so it looks to me
like dawn might be breaking now I think
so I've noticed the music's wailing
slightly gonna have a celebratory sip of
water as well like berries blackberries
I'll have you those are going straight
down right now you're just gonna be like
miles behind me aren't you you're
stopping every minute to loot or eat
some blackberries no I mean not to
partner up with you in the real
post-apocalypse head I'm afraid you're
already partnered with God oh oh oh I
find a level 9 girl I'm gonna die oh
where are you where I you are shooting
it in the leg
how are you over there I'm doing a great
job because I kept walking sorry I did I
did absolutely fine I killed them both
okay Hollywood
once again I'm over encumbered oh why
must I grab everything I see okay I'm
gonna drop some things I'm gonna say
goodbye to my Patriot suit haven't you
got a lot of weapons on you maybe I
think that's so long party hat so long
jumpsuit yeah okay I've got loads of
weapons but I like my hatchet oh yeah I
forgot to
I've got to level up do I get another
one walk straight up here I think what
I'm doing is I'm trying to do this
efficiently and sorry unofficially and
walk on the official path and yeah just
steam up the hill to you exactly we need
to nearly go oops I'm so that's it I
want to favorite you right bumper that's
favorite I want to drop my machete
plasma grenade hello panel D desk
control says take me home so here's the
problem
I currently hide it said I've identified
my issue I think you have literally a
full screen of short hunting rifles like
I like to collect them it's not my
problem oh no I dropped my good one oh
this is awful
alright I got to pick up the right one
I've just found a recipe rad stag stew
problem is I didn't kill the rad stags
when I saw them earlier so I don't have
the bits I need I did Oh shall we trade
because I did kill a rad stag I think
okay I think I mean I might I might be
lying but let me come back and we can do
a little trade I find a walking cane
okay invites trade gonna accept trade
invite okay this is all my stuff here so
you want rad stag
I guess that's in junk no misc age are
we here we aid I think it'll be in
inventory yeah this is there anything
maybe I don't I may have made that up
okay I am prepared to offer you some
crispy squirrel bits would you like some
raw robbers please notice the most best
ducks here yeah have some is best yes
yeah how do we how do we say set a price
I set my price at 6-10 it's expensive as
best I said okay how do I
oh did that work oh no I'm trying to buy
stuff when you know offers only alright
yes if you think if you push the right
stick in you get sued for his only and
you can see so yeah I'm gonna buy your
crispy squirrel bits and you can buy my
Ross best ass cool how do I select your
right trigger and you're done you enjoy
that asbestos don't eat all the once
it's I'm gonna go the top of this thing
because I've learned anything from video
games
it's climb all structures Oh a rad ride
Roach ad and radroach delicious radroach
meat ah as a guy up here and oh he has
yes things Oh a fancy capacitor oh
really
yeah let's let's read brother Moncrief
snowed brother Moncrief said High
Priestess I don't think this is meant
for me I think I was right the fireflies
come here to mate there you go a little
crazy and I got hurt pretty bad I was
able to gather enough goo to light the
lamp now I just have to wait the great
moth man will come he has to okay the
moth man cometh
so we how do we get the goo to light the
lamp what lamp boy still goes up oh this
lamp yes
oh right is in the lamp of the
lighthouse we are in I see that make
sense um I don't air sensor okay let's
retrieve me a little little sit oh yes
is really really confusing I'm light is
that I think it's time I D robes the Hat
is the environment sensor is busy
collecting data yeah I got that as well
alright shall we go on what do you think
happens if I jump from here well I die
hundred hundred percent day
I'd rather not die I've just got all
this cool stuff okay I can really do
within you jump see though I think I
picked up a new gun as well with some
sort of ivory handle I'm sure I saw that
I got a walking cane well maybe I didn't
I mean I made that up yes I did I
invented it but I did get a plasma
grenade which I will throw the next
opportunity oh oh oh
Suzie you're throwing it I mean yes if
you want to shoot throw it a radscorpion
I do where are you in the top of the is
they're still alive it's definitely not
oh I was gonna throw it to the window
never mind what do we have in here hey
these guys didn't live a particularly
full life they are dead let's move on I
think we're still got a long way to go
oh we have a you're right we have a very
very long let's let's press on yeah some
interesting things on the way so enroute
we're gonna go past what looks like a
junkyard I'm not sure where that is some
sort of farm buildings around here it is
the turtle turtle oh that guy's really
up there mm-hmm some sort of I like a
retirement community and then we have
the the water park perfect all right
let's keep going in this direction
croisine Smith says this game is
beautiful I completely agree oh I see a
weak feral ghoul forget it let's try it
let's try the fats here so it's like
real time vets
I got it didn't kill him oh I have
straight-up mister yeah that looks that
looked real good on my Jesse I was
baiting him lame get close okay I'm just
gonna swap back over to my fancy weapon
found some radaway that's good cuz I'm a
little bit of radiated canned dog food
now this brings me back to reality check
yeah because if you if someone wants to
oh yes I'm with the fact so Lewis
Darnell calculated that if you like one
single person could survive for about
fifty six years on the contents of one
kind of standard supermarket so if you
so basically if you got along in a
supermodel yeah yeah or or if you were
the only person alive and yet like the
area and there was a supermarket and you
had free reign of it you could live for
56 years if you ate things in the right
order and like an additional ten years
if you ate all the cat food and dog food
I reckon by that point you'd be pretty
much okay - I've seen walking dead they
go mad for caffeine don't remember the
episode oh I found a an oh a little
robot oh he's zapping me oh we're a
little annoying ones oh they're like oh
you're adorable and they need example
nice I think I'm using the wrong weapon
for this Oh mate this fight mate you can
find the weakest you yeah yeah look
someone's already caught some some red
stag free perfect alright and I think if
I come over to this potting station do
it raft make us astute make us us - do I
need to read the recipe first or food
reading recipes oh I definitely I
definitely need to read the recipe first
hold on
let's have a look items
recipe got alright let's make this make
it you all food oh oh no I need boiled
water spices
- Tate O's oh you're nowhere near making
that no oh you can make some much ops
though I will do exactly that
some grilled radroach and some grilled
red stag nice yeah well done cook can
make some carrot flower nectar weapons
[ __ ]
alright wonder if I can scrap some
things here it's made that ok well we
will work up towards the rad Stu the rad
stacks you looking forward to that you
ever had stag cam um I'm not sure I have
maybe maybe not realizing I was eating
stag I've had elk before when did you
eat elk that was in a place called
Lapland I remember it being quite rich I
can imagine yeah oh I can use this no
exit we had a comment from Traco asking
how he's still at level 3 well that's
probably because we haven't killed
enough people we've been exploring how
they're luring and speaking of which
let's keep going let's absolutely press
on yeah we've also not been following
the stork the quest if you follow the
main story then you know you level up a
lot quicker because you're actually
doing the things the game's telling you
to do whereas we Oh what happens
I just took damage from something yeah
I've no idea what it was I think it was
a rock I shot the rock yeah we have
decided to wander in search of a
particular giant alligator on the map
yeah I think we all know is a good idea
well we've got a finite time to stream
and I'd like to see as much of West
Virginia as possible Virginia
Shinya Oh radroach no mole-rat top
bedroom
use your head Seb there we go nice all
done oh I found it Rudi dangering it's
good news
did I win that fight I think I did Oh
another one is it No thanks for helping
they you're welcome
mysterious oh I got some boiled water
well that was something that we need for
the list for the stew you there a little
bit we need some spices I think we might
be approaching supermutant territory no
I have not seen super mutants in this
game but these blood there's one yes I
was right I saw the blood bags also all
there's a lot of them that's the history
oh they're really powerful okay this is
gonna be hard oh no one's down ones down
Ken this is this is gonna be easy
I hope Oh nearly dan reload you fool
reload
oh that's animal sound I missed him I
got him another one down come on
oh this was still here Oh oh my god
really hurt me I don't know what he got
me with but I more badly hurt I'm very
badly all right I think we're done I
think we did three surviving the musics
suggests to me that that is not the case
oh no it just they just finished whoa oh
we did it oh they have weapons that we
cannot use oh I'm gonna get over
encumber it's so fast oh wow yeah we can
take a few things here how I am quite
close to being over encumbered I lost my
eye mostly because I dropped a bunch of
stuff okay I might have to drop some
bits but um where's the other ones we
killed
that's quite exciting that was I don't
understand how we won that fight so
easily I feel like maybe I didn't
deserve I thought this dijon is really
powerful and when we found that weird
guy who had the million guns oh I think
we might have got a bit of a helping
hand there okay I'm just gonna drop some
bits to make sure I've got space for
anything Oh a blood fly gland my
favorite yeah just we need to hurry up
and get to level five so we can use some
of these new weapons
yeah well that didn't do us any harm Oh
what's this Oh big lump of meat
definitely got a lot of junk in here but
there's a safe at the top of this and a
note people like to leave notes in this
place so I really want to take these
rifles but I know I can't use them yet
but let's just hope that the time comes
where I can wear these soon is it good
let's see how long it is until I can
wear them level 15 I'm gonna leave that
on the ground because I can't wear that
I've got a few level five things level
five weapon level five weapon level
another level 5 level 10 weapon level
yeah I'll keep the level 10 but the
level 15 I don't think we're gonna reach
by the energy stream me too alright well
that went really well did you have you
run up the top of the tower I am yeah
I'm coming back there cool
yes here we go have you could taken that
note yeah I read it
yep yeah she you know what let me read
it again there wasn't really paying
attention always thinking about the
weapons I picked up so the note says
something about how there was a key
thrown off the top right on top of this
[ __ ] outside I lovely pretty pretty
sure you're walking you walking bricks
can read so good luck right okay so
there's a key for something okay on top
of can you see a toilet the toilet
outside where
it here it is oh come on
where are you it's getting a little
stuck you're underneath
yeah yeah be on top of that like I see
him yeah I got it
so where's the safe uh there was a safe
up here
oh yeah but I opened that oh no did I
know yeah I opened that how did I open
it I never the key though let me let me
up let me at it yeah I gently opened it
so I don't understand read the notes
again I want to know if there's detail
missing know that that key should be
what lets you inside this safe but I was
just able to open it up yeah well how
about you did you get the key I did yeah
I've got the key but I can still see the
key up on top of there though well I've
got you may need to pick it up yourself
interesting
we're okay well it looks like you can
pretty much get into it so there wasn't
even really anything in there worth
having not really
it was pretty minor looky there yeah
that is it yep yeah you got it no good
all right
onwards where's my waypoint this way
catching up here we go
you with me I am with you all right so
we've taken down quite a few frogs a few
super mutants nothing too challenging
just yet not just yet and we don't have
a level up yet
nope all right what's up ahead
points of interest directly add we
hitting the right way not too hungry not
too thirsty
oh well it's minus the radio frequency
am i hungry
I can't no I'm good actually Oh a little
thirsty actually hold on aid let's go
for sure got some water in here boiled
water
kind of would have thought boiled water
would quench my thirst bit more than
that but how much did you have a gallon
how big are these bottles right Danny
Derek once Derek once know can you join
up with strangers easily yes you can
yeah so anyone you meet on the you know
in the game world you can invite them to
join your team and you know they don't
have to accept obviously we've got a
voice chat turned off yeah but if you
have it turned on you can have it so
that people near you can can speak to
you which is pretty cool Oh
scorched OH oh yeah oh yeah well the
only level one they don't pretty see
that's my lead pipe I think it became my
lead pipe below that seems like a heavy
anything into hatchling to add to our
inventory so I'm gonna drop mine ladies
yeah not known for being light that's
pretty effective actually in terms of
damage oh oh we found toxic Valley what
a lovely place good to be here what is
up here
quite quite a firm of this hatchet I
made toxic Valley get to be here
what is up here
so by being in toxic Valley are we
hurting ourselves um I don't know I
don't appear be like taking extra
radiation damage or everything right now
man it's bright down here oh I see a
shed of sorts so the the map is glowing
you see that like glowing yellow there
Oh interesting
it's let's do the radio frequency I
think it could be it is so I untagged
that so if you go into your your film
app oh sorry then you can see yeah yes
you can just um I see I think how do you
you're seeing like the strength of the
radio signal mm-hmm that would be my
stop tracking yeah that did it now this
is a bit more light to fall out I
remember yeah I'm gonna hunt this deer
with a hatchet oh no I'm stuck I mean I
mean whoop I mean they're filled by this
by this shed already by a shed okay here
we go okay come here you I'm just ride
stag I didn't stand a chance I still
can't make a stew out of him knife no
with that attitude come back all right
listen so hydrothermal vents here yeah
this place is um it's quite bleak Tommy
man sir oh yeah I'm oh wow I'm getting
really irradiated yeah yeah don't don't
go in the toxic water even though I just
did that
fortunately I have some I just found an
irradiated thistle the good to the
flower of your people also I'm killing a
lot of folks over here if you catch it
here come
hello scorched whoops yes mate level six
he's stealing all my kills yeah this
hatch is really good what did I just
kill you that way well get a knuckle
duster off that person if you wanted
pitchfork hammer I'm trying to be
different we have different stuff
remember mmm we see different stuff a
multi-purpose axe
I'll take sickle nice all right
hey my hatchets covered in blood now I
guess that makes sense
oh there's a lot steel everywhere this
is a bit of a loot as paradises yeah I
say there's a lot to be taken pretty
much anything that's not nailed to the
floor
or is a sofa I found my first nuka cola
bottle
I'm gonna stay here while you
investigate I'm sensing yeah no worries
candy you take pie I'm gonna I'm gonna
take a photo is what I'm gonna do vodka
I think we haven't really explored photo
mode yet this is gonna be a great come
visit my home photo let's go wide angle
no I can actually I don't know if I can
sit on oh but I can such angle see you
from way this ramp on the depth of field
yeah yeah really go depth of field II
okay expression let's go for a worried
and brighten up a little bit here we are
whoa they've got some great filters like
this looking good yeah okay I think
we're gonna go with the nuke
I got even for that so I've I'm a nice
found quite a lot of alcohol here
vintage frame which I'm always good for
is so much you can do with these photos
yeah cool all right some great snaps
taken beautiful
alright successfully investigated should
we continue on to our destination let's
do it
all right yonder so I I don't know what
that is up there should we go check that
out where where yeah yeah that weird
sculpture last it maybe if if we like it
we can build a camp there oh yeah we
should definitely do that we haven't
done any count building but well
although we got to make sure we get to
the alligator oh one percent this was
the quest we were given no I can't climb
out that there might where this is a
this is a difficult thing to climb
alright I think success you beaten me I
have just just shooting corpses don't
mind me okay don't mind me what is up
here there is a makeshift battery it's
pretty cool wow there's a whole load of
stuff up here an Armorer's workbench oh
nice it's a wonder glue I'm gonna scrap
some bits and pieces yeah I've noticed
while you can
well we can't use the road bench at the
same time we can both scrap stuff at the
same time scratch away junk there we go
oh yeah done for that I really wish I'd
seen that before yeah that is super
helpful
alright what am I gonna craft
see what can i craft I have fits
light-armored mmm it still kind of seems
to be limited to the same things toggled
craftable items yeah
yeah you've using it and I can't now
wish to modify its all right I'm gonna
modify what kind of modify about this
wonder if that sir really helped my
carry weight a little it's a little um
I'm just improving on my leather bits
making them boiled nice yeah
I'll really protect me oh right
exit station so you're a sub I am just
gonna have a nice little out into the
wilderness now although we've been
playing with our HUDs filly on you can
if you like becoming the menu I noticed
this when I was playing on the beta you
can you can turn your HUD pasty all the
way down if you like perfect really
breathe in the atmosphere like so ah
makes such a difference
I appreciate you do need the HUD on for
a lot of things but it's quite nice so
this is like quite an interesting area
so I didn't I didn't know there was
hydrothermal like vents and pools and
stuff in West Virginia I guess there
must be but I don't feel like we really
fully explored what was down there like
what is that thing I can see through the
trees there what are you looking at
through three is almost like a structure
oh I see
that thing I'm shooting yeah oh sure
should we go see him hey see much damage
I take none nice okay so I think it was
in this I up I see it yep let's go see
who that was I feel like we haven't
really haven't really explored it
or there's a lot of petrified corpses
around here I'm gonna say is quite fun
chaining them
oh yeah because they disintegrate um I'm
just such a bullet like connoisseur
knock on a sec conservator the finest oh
so what we do not have the correct
components to repair this Oh have
clothes so okay I know one more bit of
aluminium and two more gears if you have
a let's see what I have I have basically
nothing but you do have the gears so all
we need about two years I got two years
yeah so they go so if we could just find
that last bit about a minute ago we
could understand you I turned off my HUD
so it's now hard to find you yeah
is there any aluminium in this teddy
bear otherwise oh is it can here is
there any element that's probably tin
there you go oh god I start yeah I don't
think we're gonna be able to to repair
that no all right yeah I can use can you
lead the way now because I've turned off
my HUD sure can I can I like it this way
so I'll just follow you where'd you go
this way
wait wait where are you left where
just ran away said that's what's turning
your HUD awful hardly there the HUD okay
oh I see you see all right all right
yeah let me catch it all right all right
off you go oh oh oh hold on hold the
phone but we do this oh that's a whole
lot of guys I am missed that one level
15 oh it's like the game has been like
you guys are doing too well
I'm gonna throw some tough ghouls at you
oh he's napping off absolutely not
he's cheesin it
oh hey that's oh nice Oh
oh wow this is probably the point where
I really want my HUD so I know how hurt
I am yeah I can tell you a quite time
I'm sure there's gunshot his arms oh
you're pretty hurt dude all right it's
cool I got stimpacks oh man hated an old
possum bottle all right I'll turn my
head back on case I cannot I cannot hear
this that didn't go super well for you
know like well let's see aid canned dog
food it is hot delicious I think we did
quite well there
yeah I'm not that dead I'm fine I think
well I did have a stim pack Hey we start
a new quest yes
was it dog would die off yeah okay all
right I think now we should probably
continue loot these guys I've looted
someone I only have much on them I could
tell Oh what is that what what what is
going on Reve Oh what did they all just
spawn I think they did where are they
going it's like they're all appearing
and then like now we got places to be
man we don't have time to fight you is
the ante one is the annual mirelurk
convention over here we're gonna be late
yeah he's good I don't have the recipe
for my life meat oh I shot him right in
his horrible little face didn't like it
oh they hate me for some reason
I know what did I do it's okay none of
them coming after me it is it my wooden
leg is that really rotten you can't have
it damn it
it's mine ah this guy's soft shell could
have fooled me
come on one more shot that's got it
Hey there we go happy with that yeah me
too where did they come from is that
part of the public event that we started
we started a public event I think we
might have done yeah
Oh Lord fertilizer maybe we have to try
and do these events and then things are
gonna spawn and attack us until we kind
of like you know left for dead it's not
like that until we can actually get it
done
maybe that
de Reynaud okay um I think we should go
over to the alligator now yeah I agree
okay um shall I lead the way seeing as
no yeah I can do to my got the Waypoint
on those so so yeah we've we've had a
lot of markers drop down yeah we're
that's confusing me it's all the bits we
need to complete the the current active
alright okay well we're not gonna do
that
oh but one of them yeah we're getting
close to the alligator
all right this way let's continue on you
following me I am I've also got my radar
back on so we're good so we've actually
got 30 minutes to do the dog would die
off public quest okay so it's must be
quite an epic adventure but we set
ourselves a task and will stick to it
yep I want to see this alligator
so I keep using up all my stamina why
can't I sprint oh wow
so where are you you're keeping up
you're good I'm here don't worry I'm
good I'm sorry I was just taking in the
landscape like this person this said
this person looked like they they were
petrified while stretching a lot what a
beautiful day so that's that's how I
start every morning for the first 20
minutes oh just a mirror but a cliffside
and me doing that it's horrendous all
right let's keep going
now we've not really had the the music
home particularly loud for us just to
make sure that we don't get you know
feedback into the microphones or
anything yeah but we actually had the
pleasure of meeting the composer we did
this music industry in answer you know
answer yeah so about two weeks ago we
had the fallout well it was the Bethesda
games in concert
I see the alligator sorry oh you do so
do I so do i yeah we went to the
Bethesda games in concert and it was
awesome
annoncer came up and conducted two other
pieces which was well I got a full of
energy man he is he did the world
premiere performance of the main
elderscrolls blades as well oh that too
which was cool but yes the 76 main thing
fallout 76 main theme it's really good
just impact
before we go the alligator there's this
little town let's say ten a couple of
buildings over here okay yeah shall we
investigate these so I was looking at
the map and we're alligator has what
looks very much like a slide in it yes
like I wasn't here for the waterpark
as you know but I better be moving
that'd be
anything here people just hanging out
lovely family home primary of the state
those removed from the posse what but
you're here oh well let's just stay
staying
yeah yeah weird
I didn't Kiki not yet well I already
told you first take this telephone you
never know we'll stay in close proximity
just to make sure that we end up in
there stay in the same game together
alright alright let's let's go on with
the final it's so close like we're so
close there he is
I'm just shooting at it from afar I've
got so many bullets 86 builders to get
rid of there will be so asking if
there's gonna be mods for Fallout 76 oh
I I'm sure there will be well
historically Bethesda has always
supported the modding community I don't
know how it's gonna work with oh guys
hard to shoot he is really hard to she
stopped nibbling me
oh he's diseased as well about Kanye's
oh no I bet meet this guy he was mid
grill cam I didn't he was a mid grill
what was this guy doing swimming I think
Oh
planting rifle I will take you oh nice
where did you find that it's on the
floor over here
yeah dude on it Oh another another
disease oh man thank you rad rad pop you
saved me hey I got level 4 all right
away it's all that is this wouldn't lag
I'm down you giving me we even opened a
perk pack would you like to open it oh I
found the rifle it's level 20 no oh you
got a fool
I got a perk pal like this oh wow I'm
gonna go for a mr. handy box new bar
h-he else try something classic uh so
I'm gonna go for new lone wanderer
interesting it's good for that I'm
venturing alone oh it's not gonna do me
any good today
that's okay so I thought I had to level
up as well you've done this so that's
locks because I found this card but it
is - yes much too premium for you
however do you not have cards from your
luck bit that you can add there oh maybe
maybe I do
pucks yes or they I know it's just your
charisma hey these are all I've got like
so many we got lots of lots for careers
okay cool
yeah nice really car Twp so almost air
we are arriving so I'm just trying to
figure out what this is and I thought
was a water play it is a water park
wavy Willard's
wavy Willard's presumably Willard was
the Willard was the crocodile I would
assume so or alligator heard a are we
sure which I mean based on his nose I
would say he's a crocodile I could tell
a difference I'm really like narrow
noses and crocodiles that sort of
stubble yeah maybe I'm just thinking
like I'm imagining what steve-o and used
to wrestle and he was the crocodile guy
not the alligator guy
that's true maybe this chat can help us
out with this yeah how do we know if
Willard is uh is a cult and I oh here
you're not dead before you're scorched
this scorched with your guns and you
cover it fire let's not get close to
that I got him
who's dumb trees down yeah no I can use
it though now I'm in the same situation
I'm afraid oh I can let didn't realize
that leveled up I'm opening my pack pack
you're being shot while opening up all
right pack packs later there we go
teamworks no I'm good teamwork okay
oh hold on I pass or more another one I
missed my hatchet that was doing good
okay Am I am i safe to level up as safe
as you can be
I'm doing it okay no that was me I was
that you yeah all I felt was a vibration
in the control oh there is more but I'm
gonna get them better all right I'm
gonna go for intelligence I get you know
I miss you Oh die yes I was dying so
I've come back to it Oh God yeah there's
quite a few them here I've ran bet
towards you come on come on
got him I like that he went over there
and grab the other guy's gun yeah that's
cool Oh
who's that that wasn't me there I see
him up top there this hunting rifle is
really good I did but it was level 20 so
um no right unfortunately I still can't
let's have a look okay intelligence
Colossus Mountain there he is this our
friend all right we gotta go I'm getting
real vibes and zombie live vibes here
we've made it all the way to the
alligator where I work I'm a hacker and
I'm in a gang well done folks better
recognize
Oh yours use that I thought find another
scorched don't think it's seen me yet
Oh to them there we go Oh hold still
Oh should I head shot you Oh still
scorched friend
they can't see me oh and now they do Oh
grenade forgot I had one of those I've
got some more times live not you that
work no that was useless
I missed are we loading oh I'm being hit
view them come on axe I'm running I
thought I was coming towards you but
evidently I'm no way no not leave me
alone
where are you where are you I'm getting
cornered oh god oh god run run come on
vets Oh Madison tell me at all
yeah I'm just gonna run come on level
six I'm here okay oh I got one alright
you giving me overwatch here sir I'm
trying oh yes come other one oh I'm very
I'm very hurt I'm uh I'm still being
shot it's okay that was you got that guy
nice oh one of them had a big axe and
I'm okay let's uh ready go
aide who do you who had the big X
straight for the stim pack you had
Knuckles the Echidna nowhere it
delicious okay that's good well I can't
find the axe who said she chopped me
with it twice so so these guys all have
shotguns and that explains all the
damage they're doing yeah so I did get a
shotgun but unfortunately everything
I've got is level five so close so close
I'll get there a few more of these kills
and we'll get there
right I really want to get on to the the
part with the alligator
sorry crocodile nice pick Elaine said
yeah one other one in the distance so
cam how do you activate the new bat
system you hit you hit left bumper
mm-hmm I'm a kind of highlights around
them and it gives you a nice chance of
hitting say you just hit fire so you
don't really aim ah it's kind of like a
percentage based here you go a be set on
their shop I only died didn't have to
aim or anything I'm going straight
straight up onto that slide yeah let's
do it wait where is where is the
crocodile it's back behind us literally
their Cola is this vending machine
working
it is not I'm going on the crocodile you
can you can go wherever you like we came
here for one reason and it's that giant
crocodile I am heading up here I wonder
if these guns Oh Zeb the scorched I will
try and help from all the way over here
is fine I got it
you got this Laser laser gun too big I
am too big to go down this slide all
right jumping over the security down we
go I'm just noticing having a slide cam
has a loop the loop that didn't work is
that is that a thing in a waterslide
tech can you can you loop the loop in a
water source a B oh I find miss miss
Annie he's a robot
a French robot
uh I can't really hear her and I just
want to climb it rock it out I'm sorry
I'm sorry miss Annie I'm sure what
you're saying is very interesting but I
have a call I have a crocodile life and
we all know what's more important I've
caught up so how let's see how do we get
up there I've already figured it out
oh you have if I can get up here I think
I have yes it's like the kind of theme
park that I would have really liked to
have gone to you when it's it's so steep
come on come on come on yes into the
crocodile's mouth I'll catch it up I'm
catching up there's not a lot o traps is
that a trap Wow yes yes that was a trap
yeah there's many many traps
oh I started a quest cold case
oh I'd also fell in this little gap here
oh I've got a bubblehead there we go oh
nice no I didn't get it can you not get
it here as well where is it it was on
this table no it's only one you got it
I'll trade you some asbestos for that
okay that seems like a decent trade I'm
into it okay
hey we just passed through the belly of
the well be the Beast oh I was gonna
look at her did I finally get a weapon
that I can use
seems like level five is the real you
know it's the real game changer I think
so
forget everything oh no there was
something else left on there I just got
a nice little highlight for it what was
it my box
it's a bobble head that you missed I
feel bad for you man it's not it's no
bobble heads here
all right well does this mean at some
point during this you you enter the
crocodile this way I think so don't
worry can we get on top of it that's
what I want to know like inside the
garage allows one thing I want to get on
top of the crocodile that is gonna be a
that's gonna be a tricky doable what do
you think
I'm looking I'm looking friend
I think it might I think it might be
from the mmm I don't know I'm not
convinced I'm not convinced
can I get past this without setting off
the out no work for you forget that we
can get on top of here I think we're
limited to inside the crocodile I think
we have conquered this area we have we
have there anymore who would stand
against us oh let's continue running
through the theme park ride so this
obviously wasn't although this the water
park this doesn't look like a water ride
this this was like you sure a carriage
no I'm are you sure this wasn't the log
flume oh it might been this this is what
this looks like to me
oh yeah if you're been in a real log
flume I have my be not real I've not
have you not know I've never ridden the
log flume happened in your childhood
hunting I was in Scotland there wasn't a
log flume where all our logs were used
for cavers for tossing yeah and stop
throwing them it's not writing there's
no spare logs it's a real issue okay
okay oh I can tell you exactly what this
ride used to be it was the zebra ride oh
yeah
so was I was right it's not a war ride
oh I need to drink apparently the game
has told me I must drink oh yes me too
oh wow let's let's have a drinking party
purified water oh it's so delicious
I'm done okay I'm going to go straight
for vodka that's that's not gonna quench
your thirst said and then rum oh said
and then I think I've got two bottles of
old possum they're going straight down
oh dear I look I'm not driving you home
okay you can get Oh a shotgun
well some great gear look at how uh-oh
oh wait now I'm a bit drunk [ __ ] come
here I think I might I think I might be
drinking I think this way my character
doesn't walk in a straight line anymore
oh yeah no you are definitely let's have
a look you I mean that expression hang
on is a drunk expression yeah let me
just let me adjust if I've ever seen one
yeah you're having a great time
no no you've changed
now you're sad now you're angry really
angry happy again oh that's the one yeah
there you go thank you drunk let's go
down here it says employees only but I
won't tell anyone if you don't
except stop being drunk and come here
wait
all right back to surprised this way all
right let's head down yeah I know it's
in here but I'm gonna guess ghouls oh is
this what a park valve oh yes but I just
turn on the fun I think you may have
done is there anything else we need to
press to get the water park back to life
Oh wasn't here oh I'm over encumbered
again why am I always over encumbered
think it's cuz a punishment for being
over encumbered in this game is nowhere
near as much as in a Skyrim oh wait
before we move yeah is it just that you
can't sprint he just can't sprint yeah
and it depletes your action points okay
when did I pick up a pitchfork I don't
remember that at all I'm gonna head
further into this basement all right
what kind oh whoa
how are you through the wall where did
you go I left and then oh yeah I'm
falling your way I did get a warning
that there were some scorched in here oh
what's that oh cool fusion cell I so
know these are pistol but again I didn't
get a laser no I can't use it oh it's
it's beyond my skill let's have a look
how much beyond my skill is it I think
it's yes level 5 everything's level 5
all right we have to level up before we
finish this dream okay Oh a bobblehead
ha ha
perception nice I got insurance I think
reception bobblehead you earned it
thanks Fred
oh you just continued this way it's not
backwards brain fungus harvested nice oh
I don't think this is backwards this is
rightly a deer okay wait somewhere else
interesting interesting so did we by
turning that valve making we can we make
the crocodile go is he alive now no he's
not doing anything different so I don't
think the crocodile is Wilfred or
whatever his name what's his name
Willard's Willis Wilfred close enough I
don't think that's his nick is like oh
it's a scorcher near somewhere because
there's a drawing of a man and I think
that might be Willard I think he is
Colossus the crocodile that's what I'm
going to say it's definitely scorch
still around here somewhere I got a
marker on my map for some scorch as well
yeah I can't see him
cyber exile says I long for the day's
RPGs had infinite inventory no yeah just
carry everything I do quite like the
straw that broke the camel's back like
policy of Bethesda games though yeah
it's like I could carry literally
anything and then once one too many
spoons and you're done oh there's a
snake oh my rum is worn off again
fortunate oh I see a scorched so do I
hear they will are maybe they're having
a nice time maybe were the bad guys
oh we are definitely the guys guys oh
you're down there oh another guy no a
human oh all this losses scorched
oh there's lose everything running
running running to you yeah this other
guy has walking the horrid apparently Oh
or is it just that night has fallen and
that's that's the problem possible ah
the old retreat backwards and shoots
technique oh yeah I've got grenades why
am I not using them run I'm not using
them I'm gonna try and catch up with
one here because I'm I am getting my
butt kicked grenade
I said grenade yeah how do you that
worked it's all I had
so like add that's all my grenades oh
man this isn't going well that's come on
bat 74%
hey now we're doing we get in there I'm
missing I'm trying to help you but I'm
missing
yep missed again yeah that's what that
was all year and he's calm down that's
what I need to do yeah well like I was
too far away oh you you dodged me who's
that oh that's better
you came yes no I'm good I'm good got
him the only one left I think don't here
with me oh yeah I see him oh he's gone
nicely done
yeah well haven't you the guy the other
human player he just vanished
I think he like awoke the Horde and then
ran away no he's down here okay he's
just hanging out in this pit boy oh he's
got a cool outfit going on I got ya
I like his what's he got a full like
astronaut outfit I'm giving him a thumbs
up you can get a and he's gonna get a
from from me what am i doing what I eat
it I'm seeing like join our team is
updating he's saying follow me alright
I'm gonna get generic heart we have
these guys had loads of stuff where's he
gone he said follow him and I've lost
him already immediately lost him
alright whatever you say friend I'm just
gonna go over here oh wait yeah I'm over
and come out no there is I see him crazy
we're here alright
oh poor guy is playing alone at level 10
I'm sorry not alone with us
exactly shall we invite him to our team
I just did invited him to our team I
don't know who ninja is but he's got a
cool cool outfit he deserves to be part
of our team
Pizza bomb 12 says I need a scuba
welcome aboard and in Jay says Gary
McQueen Oh
Minjae seems to have checked out yeah
yeah he's really excited better invite
ah the splish splash zone let's kill
their field we've already been here we
have all right I think we've exhausted
this alligator waterpark I think we have
yourself something up in the eye there
oh I feel like we should be able to get
in the eyes I'm certain there is a there
is more to this quest than meets the eye
oh can have a little quick drink just
gonna collect some water I'm fine for
now
all right there we go
where should we go to finish this off
serve what one final location shall we
and it's a good question I'm gonna open
up the map and take a quick Oh ninja
declined your invitation oh well screw
you
we don't need you anyway he doesn't need
whether your fancy astronaut outfit went
on space okay let's take a look at the
map where do we want to finish this off
we've made it really far to the north
really far so I mean we've got look at
all these quest markers as well yeah we
could go back to cow there's turkey or a
turtle I'm a turtle I think turtle is
where roughly where we came through
wasn't any yet yeah I think we should go
look at map in this direction somewhere
new okay let's head there let's head
there and like we've both been in market
and sign off right okay we're which way
which way there's so many markers on the
map I think we hope we'll recover it
again sorry that's quite all right let
me drop this some things there you don't
need I don't need two of these shotguns
I mean given that you can't use them
yeah I can almost use on those here very
very close yes better so company and you
could clothes oh man level five I've got
so much stuff going on at level five all
right
hi far my friend level for you where do
you see your um how close level leveling
progress yeah obviously see it but maybe
my doing oh garden oh we can gather a
log hey a collective wood that was a
challenge
oh good nice are we ten a speed
all right well I am not entirely sure
how we check level progress oh I think
I'm just uh cut really in like this this
maze oh I see I find the stairs oh my
goodness
well you were fortunately you were
getting stuck in the correct directions
yeah let's continue on up there over
there bridge well we just need to head
across the park okay so if we go down
here
oh just you Dorian
maybe we can finish off in that area and
build our our camp
that's exactly are we gonna do
well so long waterpark you were
excellent yeah it's kind of ironic that
the waterpark fill is scorched speaking
of which oh it's the ghoul yep oh and
another this one's over 15 oh wow
together we can get it Oh
treason where will be my ammo gone are
the gun that's in my way to victory
Oh God reloads Oh No
I'm really hurt help aah
take that baseball grenade that's going
oh yes
baseball grenade you say you had me at
baseball grenade where is it baseball
it's just a grenade that looks like a
baseball I mean I don't know why I'm
that excited but I am cool hold and
release right bumper to throw grenades
mines I'm throwing weapons
here's your irradiated thistle hey
flower people
fire of my really two people yes
which-which oh yeah we're still going
I'll go in this way
it's getting creepy at night it's a lot
of Jeremy says jeez a level 15 ghoul
yeah the the fact that he's level 15
hasn't seemed to be a huge problem for
us yet when we what level were the super
mutants when we found them a five yeah
cuz they they weren't too bad Don Santos
said third person so I have gone into
third person oh right yeah I've injured
it but I need to put out his misery oh
this is really sad I forget which one
what is third person again third person
so I presume if I was to put on if I
were to put on that huge hat again this
would mean third person really oh well
give it a go
that's exactly what I'm gonna do yep
yeah yeah you can't see a lot he even
needs to see Oh headshot yeah oh there
you go that's my last my level my level
I'm getting close to level five I'm
gonna literally shoot everything I see
oh I'm over encumbered God why do I have
to pick up all the things I'm gonna
Molotov everything oh I got look at this
Sam I was like maybe I can should I keep
this let eat shadow leather right are 50
level 50 yeah that's not gonna think I
might drop that yeah you're talking that
stag with the machete that's how I'm
gonna level up oh man I like how it's
supposed to apocalypse and we're going
straight back to the behavior of our
predecessors absolutely no beautiful
news we go Society oh my ghoul Oh gets
very sad take my grenade Oh another one
oh he's 15 oh he's love 15 I'm choosing
it I barely survived last time I'm gonna
take my other oh he's getting you sorry
it's harder in third person with the
shooting oh it's way harder but I'm
rating person please thank you I think
my autumn machete must be getting a
little blunt cuz as I was going with
that he
was just not getting hurt at all oh yeah
gang plus that level 500 I was getting
heavily heavily irradiated there oh yeah
me too let's get some Aid and yes hunt
all the Stags oh that just flashed
torrents flashing red over here said
sorry dieter dieter I think I found a
mine or something oh yeah what is that
what Oh Craig what are you what are ye
please just randomly explode that was
ghost officer as he just got up what is
a missing that is his backpack how weird
oh look some a solid head sorry friend
like I said yeah I mean like did he
reach conclusion with with our friend
here not really I'm a bit confused to be
perfectly honest but look it started a
new thing
it's like no discovered black bear lodge
I can't give in the window
oh I hear something it's not friendly
I'm gonna have some right away because
I'm really irradiated oh you are yeah
like not even a little bit do I even
have any right away left I do and some
red X I'm gonna rat up there we go no
more radiation is gonna get me this
looks like the kind of place I could
call home
I like the mechanics in in flight with
the you know the radiation kind of
diminishes your usable life it's quite a
nice motivator to make you yes step on
top of it yeah and jump Hey home sweet
home
lovely bet there's some some bobbleheads
in here somewhere
Oh Graham Vienna stand back well I
serenade you all I need to get the oh
hello that's why I like to keep my gun
out of ammo at all times I'm quite far
away from level 5 older land Oh goddess
course Marauder with the shotgun
Oh this place is full of scores tab
great that means we're gonna get to
level 5 it's gonna happen I'm following
it where are you scorched friends how
did they all become so scorched that's I
want to know I mean it just probably the
the massive atomic bomb but you know who
knows really who could say keeping
anything either way I'm trying to get
this makeshift battery and your big
heads in the way ooh
ammunition vending machine why don't
these exist are they probably exist I
think they do yeah I'm glad they don't
where we live okay I think I need to be
down Oh hunts master
huh I started a quest nice Oh like this
safe
requires skill to your skill zero
however I got a new hat I would like to
have you take a look at it oh yeah if
you don't find me I'm busy looting them
think you're down here Oh
oh my word beer hat that is so good it
suits you
I don't find any good hats gray fox says
Cameron serve hi hi it's good to be back
on GameSpot it is so cam let's should we
go and check out the camp system and
then I think yeah our stream oh I bet
we'll get to level five by doing some
camp system here right I so find an
aluminium can
oh wait I'm just gonna unlock a it's the
same it's the same lock-picking
mechanism for Fallout 4 it I like this
one nice oh come on Cameron you can do
this yes I can just you know just
getting clearing the path of irradiated
beings just so you can build a new there
you are yes alright I need to escape
this this place alright let's build a
camp where we gonna build oh I'm being
hurt by something what being hurt by
happened again what I just imagining to
get hurt I think someone might be seeing
me that's probably what's happening I'm
massively over encumbered again he just
yeah that's definitely some someone is
shooting something oh I hear it
yeah I'm not using that well it's cool
right I don't see anything
oh oh I saw a bullet there we go no why
am I so over encumbered
I'll still is it a scorched
I haven't landed a single one of these
shots yet say well if you there we go
there's one where are you
and that's two done oh yeah that way
oh good job yeah this looks like a great
spot for a camp I think let's do it over
here by the by the toxic stream hey they
say you should always have a water
resource right next to you let's do it
here right so hit boy move camp I will
defend you right there hey Oh Oh cam
join the fight
what is it an angler where are you oh
they're right next to me oh there's
loads of them oh this loads right by our
new camp I just put it down there what
you that's so cheeky oh oh they're
spitting toxic goo me it's my police
favorite oh man I am I am struggling
where did you all come from we were fine
and then quick quick quick
I'm on fire I'm on fire okay I'm
choosing it so long so good luck good
thing there's so few of them oh man all
I know is I'm running faster than you so
I should be fine
it's four of them and I barely heard any
of them oh my god there's a rat is just
like attack ah adding insult to injury
with this tiny rat thanks thanks friend
I did I do the same I didn't want to eat
the thistle but I guess I did oh god
they're so strong yeah they are insanely
strong Oh God no this is this is gonna
be over very soon I'm hiding in the
toxic water which is probably not my
smartest move Oh get almost impacts well
well most impacts
[Music]
they do see me chasing you I'm just
kidding you know what I'm just gonna
disappear it in the wilderness good luck
Sam no don't lead them to me that's
exactly great there's loads of rad rad
stag maybe they'll eat the rad stag
I don't have any a piece I can't
are they still chasing oh god they are
all they're all chasing you said they're
all chasing you right there why are you
leading them towards me so you can shoot
them as I lead them but I was getting
away it's getting away one of us to live
and I'm on fire now I'm on fire thanks
Seb see what you've done
oh I don't have any don't have any
weapons just run just run don't try to
fight them
they're giant angry fire fish just leave
them alone oh you know what they say
about dying building is something yeah
fish can't climb stairs that's what they
say let's let's do that
meanwhile I can see you running that way
I am running this way you can quick you
can quick menu stimpacks he realizes I
just left my camp over there as well
well I think I got away oh jeez jeez
friends like they chose to follow you
it's not my fault they thought you were
more delicious I'm going this way
actually where are you know are you
still being attacked yes I'm getting my
butt kicked
okay well you're not appearing on my map
anymore are you there all right here
come yes please haven't comes the
cavalry
please I've got so little health
I'm the worst cavalry ever oh I'm trying
I ran really far away kind of friend ie
a fast guy I'm a lot of AP all right and
I've died oh I was just here and down I
was just here that I was just coming to
help no no no feast on his corpse feast
on his corpse don't come to me a
Levangie yeah I'm sure you will you
it does nothing oh god I made the mad Oh
No
where did these even come from Oh like
I'm just not hurting them even slightly
with this gun it's like it's like
tickling them if there was one we may
have been able to kill one well I'm dead
it's okay cam you can go and pick up
your stuff but obviously don't run into
the anglers again oh if I got no stuff I
think so no I'm pretty sure I've got
some stuff but you do drop a lot of
stuff to you okay so you can read okay I
think I'm just gonna go for the go for
the kill see see what I achieve even if
it's nothing
oh I can respawn at my camp you can
respawn like right where you died I
didn't have a choice come on I mean yeah
I am tickling them but uh yeah wait can
we can we just kill one of them like
that would that would maybe film I just
want to build my camp where'd it go it's
alive Oh No wreck it yep ytb respond
here this was a horrible mistake it's
okay just multiple respawns is all we
need to get through these yeah I think
we should go somewhere else than form a
camp where there's not angry
fire fish yeah okay call for help help
I'm critically injured right well if
you've got 30 seconds I can no no I give
up
why did you respond there again let's go
let's yeah let's respond somewhere else
let's respond back at the vault yep
yeah for some e6
oh I believe I am getting injured I
think you might be so I guess we found
some high-level Emmys anyway oh well
it's good to know that the rules have
can't fast travel when enemies nearby
remain the same yeah sorry I think a
quick I could dying hideous creatures
they are like anglerfish on the body of
like a body of like a wolf yeah okay on
my way back to the vaults I'm spawn here
I'm famished which I'm gonna say is
probably the least of my issues let's
bring back the remove my camp hey what
was that creature
merlok yeah it did kind of look a little
bit like a Murloc ya know see ya but
mirelurks are a thing yeah game I'm
trying to fight we can't we can't use
our camp here we're too close to the
wall apparently all right I'm gonna eat
some food why are you loading in okay I
should be coming to join you
oh my meat spoiled I'm eating in anyway
can you get fat in this game I see a lot
to the recommend reclamation day
balloons alright let's go let's go at
least set up a camp and build something
300 years of America now we in camp we
in the camera's own yet yeah we can set
a camp what about one right here let's
do it I want to see it I don't have
enough caps to move my camp all right
you're gonna fear I've left my camp by
the angry fish be killed ease yeah yeah
these I can handle yeah he says not
handling them at all
so close to level five here we go
camp moved all right build the easement
unlocks hey I can build with your cap
too that's awesome
yeah what can I build not much I don't
have this they don't have the needed
bits from most things here say let's see
so we're not got any blueprints yet yeah
it looks like for most part we're gonna
need quite a lot of constructing
materials I don't think we can actually
I don't think we have anything to build
anything like we don't have any wood so
madney's you can use the right stick to
you search for like toggle like search
for these items oh yeah yeah of course
yeah yeah which is good see me later
Sherwood yeah it looks like this is the
kind of thing that you want to be doing
further down also I imagine all of our
things like wood and noise and stuff
what we just when we die it's got an
adorable message telling me I was
suffering water loss from dysentery very
nice this is going very well not wearing
any clothes which is really helpful with
dysentery yeah you can make a fire from
oil and wood I have neither of those
this is what I'd want to build
unfortunately we don't have I can't see
yeah there is so much stuff look at this
there is a lot of so much any item in
the game that you see walking around so
I love I really wish I had the items for
a rug just build a rug that's a hole I
can't even make patio furniture said
useless well it's early game cam so I
have nothing oh that's why because when
you die you drop all your stuff like
like if you look it that's why I
literally we can build nothing yeah it's
close we died oh well we will have to
build our camp properly on another time
yes let's finish off let's see how we
progress so you finished the game
looking pretty different yep let me just
get the the correct pose absolutely hold
on one sec expression have to be what
have you gone for my usual my usual
surprised I'm going for worried yep are
you posing these poses are great I
didn't know we had [ __ ] all right
here we go I'm posing I will also put
see this is what this game will become
for me just finding people and doing the
best possible pose so high it's my angry
face not angry hands on hips
vaultboy or you can mimic vault boy am I
surprised
no it changes I think it changes your
expression where's my guy you turned him
off you can show ya show player yeah
he's still there you're still there
I can see ya know if I do that kinda
then yeah I can yeah I'm so glad I got
my beer hat it's very good there we go I
think that's it yeah great well hope
everyone enjoyed that stream
yeah and enjoyed playing Fallout 76 with
us that was a lot of fun I I do feel my
biggest regret though is that I only
have the one piece of wooden leg armor
yeah I really wanted the whole there was
a lot of it there was a lot there to
have and I'm fortunate because it's such
a an enormous game it's the kind of
thing where we really need to explore
for a long long time but yeah that was
just a taste that's the first I guess
two hours and approximately 15 minutes
of the game is like us yeah yeah it's
one potential route if you want to go
straight to the the crocodile yes we did
I would love to dig more into the story
that leads you around that that water
park yeah cuz I feel like especially
when we found the valve to the water
there is an adventure to be had there
yeah I think that's one best it's best
done with you with your own group I
think yeah big Jerry says said logic at
least you're naked yes it was that did
you said that it was big journeys all
right okay yes good okay yeah thank you
very much everyone who tuned in to to
watch us
I hope that you'll all jump in and have
a go at fallout 76 as well it's one of
those games having played now and also
having played fallout 4 and previous
well as as well that playing with
someone else is a lot of fun it is very
it's very different and it because they
you're so used to doing these things in
your own yeah be able to just adventure
off and and so it adds so much being
like oh you know we need to move
together or if I'm gonna wander off
stairs probably gonna be looting for
half an hour and it makes you realize
people play these different these games
and read different ways yes so you can
kind of you know combine that I think
it'll be a lot of fun but I think
certainly for me the thing I'm gonna
enjoy the most is just the wandering
into the wilderness with somebody else
and just see what you find
yeah exactly well there is a lot to be
found I'm definitely gonna be playing
more of this hopefully we can build a
camper when we've not immediately just
yeah well back and get our things and
hopefully the anglers will have left mmm
otherwise we're just gonna get stuck in
it incredible loop of death it was
interesting though how the anglers are
the only enemies that posed like a real
threat to us yeah everything be able to
like handle it's not acid like the acid
spits on fire yeah I yes I I don't know
how we handle that no all I can say is
we handled it poorly yes yes well thank
you very much for joining me it's really
nice to to play alongside because
normally I just like a much better game
drivers I don't think that's true but I
think the rules informant
it's good it's good to not be the only
one playing that was that was a lot of
fun but thanks very much to Bethesda for
c1 spring today's stream yep don't
forget to check out fallout 76 it is
reclamation day today so it is
outsourced don't forget to go and yeah
get playing when you're playing on xbox
one way today and if you want to know
anything else about the game make sure
you check out all of the coverage on
gamespot comm see you later
you
[Music]
[Music]